former teen idol David Cassidy is being
remembered this morning for his
contributions to the music world
[Music]
love it The Partridge Family star and
Grammy nominee died yesterday at age 67
Cassidy had dementia
he was hospitalized in Florida with
organ failure Anthony Mason is here
Anthony good morning good morning David
Cassidy was born in New York City and
had performing in his genes his dad won
a Tony Award and after his own brief
appearance on Broadway Cassidy moved to
Los Angeles in 1969 and hitched a ride
on a star David Cassidy got his big
break and a number-one record as
heartthrob Keith Partridge in the hit
series The Partridge Family really where
he starred alongside his real-life
stepmother Shirley Jones but the pure
magic happened in front of his adoring
crowds his shows were described as
Cassidy me
[Applause]
[Music]
he was the teenage dream for teenage
girls of the 1970s in 1972 he posed
naked for a Rolling Stone cover and
inside discussed his drug use
all told Cassady sold more than 30
million records and managed to pack big
venues like Madison Square Garden in
1974 the hysteria led to tragedy when a
teenage girl died after a stampede at
his London Show
[Music]
cassadee continued to tour in recent
years but his help made performing
difficult to watch her mother disappear
it's very painful he stopped in March
after he shared his diagnosis of early
dementia a condition that was hereditary
through it all his fans never left him I
think you try and stay with your
restraints which is for me is to go out
and connect and entertain and make
people laugh and get him stomping and
clapping and walking out with a smile on
your face two notable tweets on the news
first from Micky Dolenz of the Monkees
who called him a formidable talent and a
really really funny dude and maureen
mccormick Marsha Marsha Marsha of the
Brady Bunch of course who wrote deep
down I dreamt of being a partridge I've
gone way too soon sixty-seven Anthony
thank you